Inside Edition anchor Deborah Norville
is using her personal journey to help us
live more positively she shares that
message in the latest book in the
Chicken Soup for the Soul series it's
called
Chicken Soup for the Soul think positive
live happy the book includes 101 unique
stories about optimism faith and
strength - its distributed by Simon &
Schuster which as you know by now is a
division of CBS so since 1993 more than
100 million copies of Chicken Soup for
the Soul books have been sold in this
country and Canada there are more than
250 titles in the series and Deborah is
a co-author of the latest book she wrote
the introduction and she helped select
the essays from thousands that were
submitted and joins us at the table hey
Deborah Norville good morning everybody
and you lead with your own story because
you said my Depression was there for the
world to see we had some changes at NBC
in the Today Show you can remember a
headline very vividly about you that
said what it was an article in the
Chicago Tribune that said of June Thank
You Chicago Tribune left for dead by the
side of the road that was how they
described my career and it was
absolutely correct there was well that's
how you were feeling
no that was how I was and no one would
have bent 50 Cent's that I would have
gotten my career back that I would have
been back on television that it would
been a part of you know a book series
like this so but you know what you said
this is what I like you said you don't
so much when stuff happens yep life as
it does to all of us it's not so much
about moving on it's about moving
forward yeah through challenges through
grieve through disappointment what's the
difference between moving on moving well
you know I that was taught to me my my
friend whose husband died in the
September 11th terror attack and I had
talked about moving moving on and she
said no no no no no she corrected me she
said you do not move on you move forward
sense you take that with you but you
move forward in life because that
experience has become a part of you and
and keep it with you keep the learnings
from it with you but move forward and
get get getting new things going in your
life there were thousands of stories
submitted them oh my god it was so hard
to pick how did you pick sometimes it
was just like you know we've got too
many where it's focusing on somebody who
lost their job we can't do anymore of
those I lost my job stories so we're
gonna save that for when we do the 100
one stories about losing my job so we've
only tried to keep it in segments and
variety there's just a variety of is
there any one that particularly struck
you oh my god there's one that I love
and I think Gil this is one of your
favorites this is a woman who had lost
her job she'd gotten her pink slip that
day she's got six kids she's in the
grocery store she's weeping as she's
doing her marketing and she saw a bright
yellow envelope stuck in between the
meat in the meat counter she picked it
up she opened the envelope and it said
everything will be okay oh you are fine
you are going to be fine it was like how
did this person know it was karma she
paid it forward she started a social
media movement where she's sharing that
message and it lands in your lap on the
day you need it to make a stranger's day
and then she ended up meeting the lady
yes this is a book about optimism
optimism studies to actually show they
can help you live longer right and this
is what's so crazy and that's why this
book is so useful particularly right now
right we're talking the beginning of the
hour about impeachment a lot of people
are understandably stressed about what's
going on in politics in this country
when you read a book like this it will
make you more optimistic and the Harvard
School of Public Health
two months ago published a study that
said people who are optimistic live on
average 11 to 15 percent longer I
believe and they have a 50% greater shot
at making 85 Wow I believe that just
your minds there's a story about the
power of now when it comes to dating
because so many people are looking for
forever yes there's a great story of
where the guy says look I'm not looking
at forever how about just right now yeah
yeah this was the ladies were divorced
and after three years she finally
started dating again she was a nervous
wreck about it and she goes out with
this very lovely man and he could sense
her you know discomfort he says look I'm
not looking for forever I just want to
have a nice evening and and that was her
message she says don't spend so much
time worrying about the future that you
miss them now yeah and then now is
usually pretty good every one of us has
something good in our now and my mission
is to help you focus on that and when
people get this book could you go to 78
and read can't is a four-letter word we
don't have to' okay
levy to kill I will support letter word
yeah thank you guys everything here
thank you very much
Chicken Soup for the Soul think positive
lib happy is available now